It's easy enough to say I'm going to
start learning this language, but I know
from experience, it's a lot of work.
Hi there's Steve Kaufmann here.
Today I want to sort of ask
myself a question: why do you
want to learn another language?
Um, and, um, but first, before I
get into the subject, uh, if you
enjoy my videos, please subscribe,
click on the bell for notifications.
And if you follow me on a podcast
service, please leave a review.
So why has this subject
suddenly come to my mind?
Well, my, a large part of my inspiration
for learning languages comes from
different series that my wife watches on
Netflix and I kind of go in and out of the
TV room and sometimes sit down and watch.
And she was watching an
Indian movie ... or something.
Uh, and of course it's, it's
in Bombay it's a hundred years
ago or whenever, 80 years ago.
And it's very exotic and all of these
things that sort of, you know, and
of course I pick up the odd word in
Hindi that sounds a bit like Persian.
Uh, the odd one and it then becomes
very tempting to say, you know what,
I should learn Hindi or Punjabi
or one of those Indian languages.
And so then I say to myself,
well, here you are, you've been
struggling with Persian and Arabic
and of course neglecting other
languages that you've learned.
Why would you take on
yet another language?
And, um, yeah, this is
an interesting question.
Obviously, the more languages you
have or the more languages you try to
learn, uh, the less well you're going
to speak in languages that you have
already spent time trying to learn.
You know, I sometimes say to
myself, why did you ever bother
trying to learn Persian and Arabic?
When, you know, I, maybe you should
focus on Korean, which is not
at a level that you would like.
Um, and, and the, the simple answer
is that I'm always curious, you
know, as imperfect as my Arabic and
Persian are, and I will perhaps do
a um, maybe a conversation with my
tutor again, in those languages, and
you'll see that it's full of holes.
And yet it's at a level
where I enjoy them.
Uh, I enjoy listening to my, um, you know,
Radio Farda uh, podcast news in Farsi.
I understand a fair amount of it.
I enjoy, for example, my Jordanian.
Um, cartoon series.
So I'm enjoying participating to
some extent in that language, in
that culture, however imperfectly.
So whatever I put in, I feel I get back.
Now, how exciting would it be to have some
sense of how some Indian language works?
Uh, probably Hindi because
it's the most widely spoken.
And of course the Bollywood movies are
in Hindi, but here in Vancouver, most
of the people from India are in fact
from the Punjab so they speak Punjabi.
Um, probably I have no idea how mutually
intelligible those languages are,
but, um, it would be fun to do them.
And so it becomes fun.
Uh it's it's a challenge, like part
of learning another languages simply
because the language is there.
So it's like, why do you climb a mountain?
Because the mountain is there.
You know, uh, I look back to when I
wrote my book The Linguist on Language,
uh, I guess I was 57 or so and I
had nine languages and I had enjoyed
every one of those nine languages.
Well, now I'm approaching
my 20th language.
Um, mostly since the age of 60 and it's
brought me so much and I can think of the
Egyptian movies that I watched training
very hard to understand something,
not understanding too much, but, but
because of my exposure to that language
and the few things that I do understand
I'm more involved, I, I can feel and
smell and touch the culture more.
Uh, similarly with Persian, where Sahara
in Iran has sent me some, uh, Irani
movies and I'm confident, maybe more
confident in Persian than in Arabic,
that I'll eventually be on, be able
to understand those movies quite well.
Uh, so it, it brings me all of that.
And I think I made the point in,
in a number of my other videos
that whatever I achieve is good.
It's all a plus.
There is no negative.
Perhaps the only negative is that
I haven't spent that time working
on some of my other languages,
but I can go back to them.
Whatever I put into them is there.
I'm not going to lose it.
It might take me a little
while to refresh them.
So I don't know, why
learn another language?
I guess the question can be asked
of someone like me who has tried to
learn, say, 20 languages and who might
look at trying to learn about another,
yet another language or two or three
or someone who is still struggling
with their first foreign language.
And of course, for many
people, it's not a hobby.
For many people, it's, it's,
there's a practical need.
Uh, they might be an immigrant or a
refugee in a country, in Germany or
in North America or somewhere they
have to learn the local language.
Or, uh, if you're living somewhere
where you do business with people
from another country and you need that
language, then of course there's a
greater sort of need for the language,
but I'm not in that situation.
I'm in the situation where I
learn languages for pleasure.
And uh, why would I take on yet another
language with all of an, and of course
it's easy enough to say I'm going to
start learning this language, but I know
from experience, it's a lot of work.
So once I commit myself to sort of
spending time with that language, it's
going to be another sort of times sump,
but it's an enjoyable pursuit for me.
Uh, and not only is the actual study of
the language enjoyable, but everything
that comes with it, the discovery
of the culture, getting closer to
those people and seeing those people
less sort of in a caricature form or
stereotype form, but rather seeing
them as they are and hearing how they
speak and how they express themselves.
So that's why I continue to add
languages, although I don't achieve a
high level of fluency I do achieve a
very worthwhile level of familiarity
with those languages and that's why
I would continue learning languages.
And I would like to suggest you
have a look at two languages or two
videos that I did on the subject.
Uh, one was six months ago where I
talk about learning two languages at
once and another one, three months
ago, where I would talk about learning
multiple languages at the same time.
And that might give you a different
perspective on the issue of taking on,
uh, different languages or continuing
to challenge yourself with more
languages when you already know some.
And I'm sure I'm not the
only one in this situation.
So I look forward to hearing from you.
Bye for now.